皆さま
明けまして
おめでとうございます
2017年、はじめしゃちょーです
私は
2017年どうこう言う前に
ひとつ
やらなければいけないことがあります
去年！
2016年1月13日
私は動画で
こう言いました
（お菓子を食べません！）
*泣*
それから月日は流れ
約1年
350日程が経過しました
お菓子が
食べれるようになりました
私はあの日言った通り
2016年はお菓子、ジュース1つも食べませんでしたああああああああ
辛かったよ
僕のチャンネルすっごい昔の動画から見たことある人ならわかると思うんですけども
ほんとに初期はお菓子の商品紹介をしてました
ふっw
今となっては信じられないでしょう
コンビニで働いてたんで
新商品が出たらすぐわかるんで
お菓子の情報誰よりも早く取り入れてたんで
商品紹介のプロだったんすよ
お菓子の商品紹介するくらい僕笑顔でお菓子食べながら毎日YouTubeやってた男が
2016年去年に関しては
お菓子を食べることすらもしない
1年を送ってたわけですよ！どう思いますかこの現実を！
俺にとっては！非常に苦しい！1年だった！
あ、そうだ　あの母ちゃんからなんか届いてたんだった
取ってきます
よいしょ
僕今年実家帰れなかったんですけど
母ちゃんから贈り物が届いてるんで開けてみます
なになに？
なにこれ？
なんかすごい、こんなのが入ってたんですけど
あざっす
うーーーわ
うっはwwちょっと待って
まじか
全部お菓子なんですけど
うーーわ　母ちゃんこれは
ちょっと待てよw
母ちゃんこの量はやばいよ
てことはまさかこっちも
あ、でもジュースだ
すっげーゴリゴリジュースやん
うわすごいな
これは何もう
これは何？
おせち料理贈ってくれたの？
え、なに　もう完全おせち料理じゃん
というわけで母ちゃんからおせち料理が届きましたー
すごいなー
あ～もうオイラの好きなのしか入ってないよ
全部お菓子じゃないすか母ちゃん
全部お菓子じゃないっすか
母ちゃんごめん
自分でも買ってきちゃった
貰えると思ってなかったら自分でめっちゃ買っちゃったよ
はいというわけで皆さん　ご覧のとおりなんですけど
いつも僕のことをディすりしかしない母ちゃんが
これだけ気を使ってくれるくらい
実は辛い1年でございました
まずそもそもなんでお菓子を禁止しにしたかっていう話になるんですけど
禁止にした理由はやっぱ体の健康を気遣って
1日3食全部お菓子の時とか普通にあったんで
それくらいお菓子が大好きで
さすがの親も心配してくれて
ちょっとお菓子食べ過ぎじゃない？って話になって
お菓子を禁止してたんですけども
お陰様で体はかなり健康だったと思います
厳しいスケジュールの中でもなんとかやってけたんで
お菓子食べるよりかはマシな物食べてたのかなと思ったんですけど
やっぱね
今の名言ですよ
あのそうなんかねー
いいんですけどーやっぱお菓子美味しいんすよ
お菓子って何がすごいって言うとやっぱ
食べるとね心が幸せになります
心が健康　心が幸せになる
改めてお菓子の大切さに気づかされた1年だったと思います
無事なんとか1年間乗り越えて
ようやくここまで来ましたかという話でございます
頑張ったオレ
ほんとねーお菓子がないときつかったよ
え、待って！
ミスタードーナツも食べれるやんけ
編集中に食べるお菓子がないのがホント辛かった
オイラの心の支えがないと言っても過言ではなかったから
視聴者の皆さんにも色んな人に頑張れ頑張れって言っていただいて
最初の1,2ヵ月はほんとに誘惑との戦いだったんですけど
その1,2ヵ月さえ我慢できれば意外とさらっとイケましたけど
たまーにすごい食べたくなる時がありました
もうそこは気合いで堪えるしかなかったんで
ほんとに僕は2016年を通して
精神力がかなり付いたと思います
忍耐力、我慢することの大切さ
人間的に1つステップアップできたのではないかなと思います
350日ぶりにお菓子を食べてみようと思います
うわ緊張するな
あのなんかもう
1年くらい食べてないともうお菓子買うことに罪悪感があって
すごいきょどりました買う時に
わかんないわかんない　どうどうどうお菓子に接したらいいかわかんない
やばいな
完全復活だよ
もう頭が働かない
もうクリエイティビティが完全に止まってて去年は。
甘い物を食って脳がハッピーになると
僕は普段の力が解放できるので
2017年は食べ過ぎないように
お菓子をたくさん食べようと思います。
最初に何食べると思いますか？ちなみに。
もう僕決まってます
もう絶対これだと思ってました
カントリーマアムのバニラ味です
格別大好きってわけでもないんですけども
これすごい好きで
まあ全部好きだよ
全部好きだけども
これからまずは始めようかなと思います
うわーいよいよ食うのか
では皆さま
2017年も何卒よろしくお願いいたします
食べます
いただきます
あ、やばいやばいやばいまじで緊張してきた
すっごい悪いことしてる気がしたんだけどw
いや悪いことしてません
新たな1年のスタートです
乾杯
あはんちょ～～とほんとに食べていいの？
あーーー
思い出すなー
これがお菓子か
なんか久々すぎてリアクションが取れねぇ
どう、どういう反応すればいいんだ
おわーー
うまい！
あーやべ　完全に力がみなぎってくる
半分だったパワーが今フルパワーになってるくらいの勢いです
コーラも飲んでいいんすよね
え、もう完全に俺の時代じゃんこんなの
え、飲みますよ？
あーーやべー
これがコーラか
うわうわうわオランジーナじゃん
ちょちょいちょいちょい
おっうおおっおおお！！
幸せだーーー！！！！
うわもうこピザポテトー
はいというわけで350日間ぶりにお菓子を食べてみたところ
結果は
尊かったです
なにかを我慢する力というのは大切です
僕は1年間お菓子を食べれないという条件と引き換えに
そして
開放感を得ることができました
ふっはっはっはっはっ
今年の俺は
フルパワーだああああ！！！！
今、何個か食べたんですけど
めっちゃ気持ち悪い
体質が変わったのかな
お菓子食べるとすごい気持ち悪くなるんですけど
すっごい今気持ち悪いもん
コーラはうめーな